all right can i just start
yeah i think you should just start yeah
i don't know who you are
um welcome everyone especially those of
you for whom the
local time zone is outside of normal
working hours really appreciate you
being here
uh so this morning we will do a
review of common techniques and
algorithms in online learning and mdps
and i hope that this will start bringing
together some of the things we learned
yesterday
starting from basic planning what is the
value function
what are optimal policies and then we
also looked at some bandit techniques
some of those techniques will make
reappearance uh
in the two parts in this section on
online learning and mdps
my job in part one is to give you
some exposure to online learning in a
fixed mdp so the mdp is not going to
change
as the learner interacts with mdb and
then my talk will be followed by
gurgle's presentation where he's going
to talk about
the changing mdp setting which obviously
is more challenging
and feel free to stop me i purposefully
kept the number of slides
uh low so please feel free to just stop
me and ask questions
all right so
uh the outline is very simple i'll give
you i'll sort of situate the ucrl2
algorithm which is the main algorithm
i'll focus on today
uh it is historically important it
started off a whole sort of series of
papers analyzing regret in
online mdps
and so i'll focus on just one algorithm
give you pointers to other algorithms
i will go a little bit uh deeper into
the analysis like what is the main
technique uh used to show the regret
bound and then ended
end with some high level discussion
okay so just to sort of situate this
whole business of regret analysis mdps
within the
uh sort of the rl world uh as i see it
there are
two strands of research that are
directly responsible for use for an
algorithm like ucrl2 what does ucrl mean
it means
upper confidence bounds applied to
reinforcement learning and the 2 stands
for the version there was an earlier
version ucrl
which required more assumptions you said
l2
works under less stringent assumptions
so there's a strand of literature that
connects to bandits especially
the ucb uh literature
and it's that's no coincidence because
one of the authors it's like there's a
common author
uh peter hour who also is an author on
the ucb paper and on the ucl2 paper
but but the other strand is
reinforcement learning itself and this
idea that
maybe we want to analyze theoretically
how well an agent is doing
in one long interaction with an
environment model as an mdp
so the use of the term reinforcement
learning as a computer science technique
not in the sense of psychology to the
best of my knowledge goes back to
a very influential paper that marvin
minsky wrote in 1961
titled steps toward artificial
intelligence
and interestingly uh in apparently
independently of minsky
walls and foo used the same term in the
title of a paper that appeared in the
control
theory literature and what is surprising
is that 1970s was pretty much
a very slow period for reinforcement
learning not much happened
even though in 1960s people were
starting to get this idea that we can
uh maybe create agents by using ideas
from uh
psychology by trial and trial and error
learning using rewards
but 70s was kind of a dull period and
really
the field started to uh gather momentum
in the 1980s
uh temporal difference uh all these
famous methods that you
hear about now were invented and at
least
some some basic analysis was done in
that era and then by the end of 1990s
there were enough results
uh that the first book came the first
edition of saturn and marto came out
which is a very good
introduction to the field of rl uh it's
actually not that technical so
i have regularly assigned it to
undergraduates and then they get a lot
of value out of it especially the early
chapters
and there was a influential survey
written in 1996 by gail blink
littmann and moore i was rereading it
uh while preparing this tutorial and i
was very surprised to find the sentence
so i quote from that paper they say so
they're discussing how to evaluate
theoretically evaluate reinforcement
learning algorithms and they say
unfortunately results
concerning the regret of algorithms are
quite hard to obtain
and that gave me a really nice feeling
because you know within a span of about
10 years
so late 2010s the first results on
regret analysis in
in reinforcement learning started to
come up so uh
a landmark result was a landmark
algorithm was this algorithm called eq
which i'll talk very briefly about and
another related algorithm called rmax
and then another milestone was uh sham
kakida's thesis
in 2003 which this thesis was also
mentioned in mangy's talk
yesterday and then the focus of today's
presentation
uh is the ucrl2 paper uh three authors
um uh we published in jmlr 2010
and it's really kicked off this area of
sort of rigorous uh
regret analysis in mdps using one
long interaction with mdp so no resets
it'll be not in the episodic setting
and there was an earlier conference
version in 2008 so that's
that's kind of historically where we
have situated the paper that we're going
to look at
and just a word about what do we mean by
uh
online learning because online learning
has slightly different meanings
it could be mean maybe you're designing
online learning algorithms which is
prediction
maybe you're in full information you saw
bandits
uh but today we are going to look at
online learning where an agent
is interacting sequentially with a
markov decision process
and so the experience arrives bit by bit
you take an action
you see the state you went in you see
the reward
so slowly maybe you build up your
knowledge about the system
and in online learning there is
typically no difference between there's
no separation between an explicit
learning phase where you can just do
unbounded amounts of exploration and
separate evaluation phase where you will
be
evaluated it may make sense in some
applications i'm not saying that that's
not a useful separation but
in the setting i will talk about that
separation is not going to be there
so then there is a explore exploit
trade-off
uh which is obviously also there in
bandits but it's even more pronounced in
some sense
uh in the in the mdp setting and the and
this trade-off has
to do with the fact that the agent is
faced with this
slightly contradictory goal of having to
learn about the system
and also taking good actions
right so maybe the tension is because
maybe sometimes you have to take bad
actions just to learn
bad actions meaning actions that are not
immediately rewarding
and so to as one theoretical way to
measure how good an agent is
at resolving this trade-off we might
look at the rigor and again regret is a
very general notion
it has different instantiations
uh in specific problems and in specific
analysis frameworks but it usually
refers to a difference it's a
performance measure which is in the form
of a difference
difference between what difference
between some
yardstick some comparative some
benchmark level of performance that
maybe you can only achieve if you had
full knowledge of the system
the difference between that performance
and the agent's
actual performance how much reward did
they actually get in
let's say some fixed number of
interactions in the system
and so this part deals with this explore
exploit trade-off
as viewed through the lens of rig right
analysis
in a fixed mdp and then part two we'll
look at look at the
changing individuals see there's a
question
oh i guess someone already answered
um
and just just before we delve into the
the algorithm and the analysis uh just
one word about the role of theory this
is a
we're in a simon's institute for the
theory of computing it's a theory of
idle semester
and i really feel that right now we
probably at the
start of another golden age of theory
for rl because there's so much
applied empirical work that has happened
so many empirical successes
a lot of opportunity for theory and i
love this quote from this book
uh computer age statistical inference uh
written by
uh brad afron and trevor hastie one of
two of the most famous statisticians
alive
and they say in the early in the book
that
if the inference algorithm raise is a
tortoise and hair fair
and by inference just think by influence
they really mean
why algorithms work right so there are
algorithms and then there are reasons
why they work
so let's call those reasons sort of
inference why algorithms work
so if the if the influence algorithm
race is a tortoise and hair affair
then modern electronic computation has
bred a bionic hair so the hair is really
running away
much faster the methods and the
algorithms are just being developed
at a breathtaking pace right now
especially deep
has really taken off in the last five to
six years
and a quick search on google scholar
just looking at reinforcement learning
in the title of papers
so that's an undercount uh we see that
there are
over 16 000 papers in the last decade uh
compared to only six thousand
in the decade previous to that and i
think this is only going to increase so
2010 to 20 20 20 to 30 we'll see another
maybe factor of three or four i don't
know how to predict
uh and the field has grown uh southern
part of second edition which came out
2018 is about
twice as big uh by the author's own
estimation
the theory tortoise because it moves
more slowly has lots of catch up and i
hope that this program
can can read a faster tortoise just like
the electronic computation has bred a
faster hair
okay so i want to lead into the ucl2
algorithm
but i want to talk about very briefly
two other landmark algorithms e cubed
and r max
before i get to ucl2
so i'm not going to go into the details
of ecubed and rmax just give you a very
brief overview so e cube the name comes
from the three words
explicit explore or exploit that's why
it's called eq
and it was a landmark paper because uh
it kind of
brought these this view of uh looking at
the sample complexity looking for
polynomial bounds
uh coming from like theoretical computer
science and and especially
a valiance 1984 framework of back
learning
and it examined reinforcement learning
from that that perspective that we want
to give guarantees theoretical
guarantees that
learning happens efficiently and
efficiently hopefully it's both
computationally efficient and sample
efficient
and here the part as i will not go into
the details the only thing i want you
to sort of know from from this brief
overview if you
don't already know e cube uh then the
one thing i want to point out
is that this algorithm makes an explicit
distinction between known states of the
mdp and
unknown states of the mde which of
course this distinction known and
unknown changes over time as the learner
visits more states than mvp
the number of known states is going to
increase but it does maintain
at every point in the algorithms
interaction with the environment it
maintains explicit distinction between
known states and unknown states
and if it visits an unknown state and by
the way the distinction between unknown
and unknown states
is is decided by the number of times
you've visited the state in the past
so if you land up in an unknown state
you just do balance what they call
balanced wandering you just take the
least right action so you just explode
and you also maintain a partial model
why is the model partial because
it's it's only good on them on the set
of known states you have no idea what's
going on
outside of the set of known states you
don't have enough experience so you have
a partial model of the mvp
so it's a model based method but it only
maintains a partial model maybe the
model will never be a good model
everywhere it just depends on what
happens
and the key the key sort of design
principle in this algorithm is an
explicit separation of exploration and
exploitation what does that mean
so at high level what it means is that
the agent
performs two calculations
okay so it says well given the partial
model right now
is there a policy which will give me
high returns high rewards
uh based on that partial model alone
so that's the attempted exploitation and
also ask the question
is there a policy which will very
quickly take me out of the set of known
states okay so maybe i can
i can go and learn something about the
unknown states
uh and then the key analysis technique
is to show that
it cannot be the case that both of these
attempted steps fail so one of
attempted exploitation or exploration
will succeed
um that's the famous explorer exploit
lemma and then there's also a simulation
glamour which says that
the value of the policy in the actual
mdp restricted to the known states is
actually close to what you think it is
based on your partial body
so that's that's kind of the uh the
basic idea behind eq
and so as i said it was landmark paper
this was followed by rmax
where rmax the step forward was
considerable simplification in the
design of the algorithm
removal of this explicit distinction
between
known and unknown states sorry sorry
it retained the distinction between
known and unto unknown states
but it removed this explicit explore
versus exploit
design so it used optimism in the phase
of uncertainty principle which we saw
yesterday
that it's a principle that says that if
you're in uncertain environment you're
making decisions you have some authority
maybe
maybe behave as if it's the best of all
possible words
uh and in our max how it is instantiated
is that in the unknown states you just
assume that they're
fully rewarding so if reward is in some
scale 0 to r max
you just say i get a maximum reward r
max in the unknown states
uh some often in theoretical rl we
normalize the reward so that they're in
the interval 0 to 1 so then our max is
just one then you will just put a one
in the states that are unknown okay so
this was another landmark because it
achieved the simplification of the
algorithm and it also connected to this
uh
this general design principle of
optimism in the face of uncertainty
and what was interesting is that they
analyzed not just mdps but actually
stochastic games two player stochastic
games
so they went a little bit beyond the mvp
framework
oh there's some activity in the chat i'm
should i be
oh okay that's just java mickey man yeah
never mind it's just me
no worries i just thought maybe
someone's asking a question of chat
okay i tell you if there is a question
oh thanks yeah that would be nice
okay so just one slide on on the general
of you principle
if you were not in the tutorial
yesterday uh then i
want to make sure that everyone at least
has some idea of what we mean by this
principle as i already said is this idea
that if you have some uncertainty about
the true
true nature of the world then maybe
behave as if it's the best of all
worlds that are somehow consistent with
your experience so far so that's
that's the high level intuition behind
the technique
and it has it has a i think a
a long history i it definitely appears
in that survey that i talked about 1996
survey by kell bling lichtman and more
the section called ad hoc techniques it
just appears there because
back then i believe there was not enough
understanding of whether you could
actually theoretically
uh prove something about this type of
principle and the
certain part of first tradition also
talks about that you know this is
this optimistic they talk about
optimistic initialization
and they say it's a simple trick that
can be quite effective on stationary
problems there was a sense that maybe
it's just a trick or an ad hoc technique
so it was nice that we could then later
on come up with theoretical vigorous
justification behind
particular instantiations of the wave
principle
it's also related to ideas and control
i'm no expert in control but
i at least know that there are papers on
cost biased maximum likelihood
estimation
uh and and something called the bet on
the best principle
which is very much related to workflow
so just a summary of the introductory
part of the of the talk if now we'll get
into the actual ucl to algorithmic
analysis
uh i want to sort of think i want you to
think of the evolution from
e cube to r max to ucl2 as
uh sort of elimination of explicit
uh things in the algorithm so eq both
had the explicit distinction between
known and unknown states
it also had the explicit distinction
between oh am i exploiting am i
attempting exploration or exploitation
and it didn't in any explicit sense
embodied the of you principle
so that's the eq row then rmax came
along and said well let's keep this
explicit distinction between known and
unknown
let's remove this explicit distinction
we explore exploit let's just
of principle will take care of that we
will just
initial we will just put our our max on
unknown states and then the agent will
naturally either explore exploit we
don't have to worry about
explicitly making the agent do that that
trade-off
and ucl2 said well let's even eliminate
this distinction between known and
unknown states
it's anyways a little bit artificial to
say that beyond a certain count
the state has become known maybe we just
retain some soft
notion of how uncertain a state is by
just keeping track of counts
but we are not going to distinguish in
this black and white equation between
known and unknown states
okay so okay so so what is the actual
ucl2 algorithm
uh the algorithm is going to run in
episodes and i want to make sure that
there is no confusion on this
point you can use an episodic framework
to analyze reinforcement algorithm where
the episodic nature
is built into the framework so the
episode maybe lasts
some fixed number of steps the agent
interacts interacts interacts and maybe
then gets resets to
some initial state or initial stem
distribution here
our framework is not episodic our
framework is that the agent is just
interacting with mdp one long trajectory
no resets so the framework is not
episodic
but the algorithm is going to have its
internal episodes
and what is the definition of the
episode in ucl2 an episode is simply
a a duration of time where the algorithm
is sticking to
a fixed policy okay so the algorithm
design will involve episodes even though
the analysis framework doesn't have any
episodic nature to it
and this trajectory s1 a1 r1 x2 a2 r2
state action reward
triples you see them we will compute the
regret
at some finite length capital t
we will work with a tabular mdp for now
uh with the finite number of states
s finite number of actions per state a
and the reward function r and b so
mostly standard notation so hopefully
that doesn't
confuse anyone and the high level
description of the algorithm is as
follows within any episode
where you're going to stick to a single
policy you're not going to change the
policy inside of an episode
so within an episode use your collected
statistics
what statistics you create statistics
out of the trajectory you create these
counts how many times did i visit a
particular state action pair
how many times it happened that when i
visited
s a i transitioned to some fixed s prime
what are the counts
so these statistics use these statistics
to create a set
of launchable mdps mdps that don't seem
to have been ruled out
by the data have so far seen so that's a
set of possible mdps the true mdp may be
somewhere in the set next step
find the most optimistic mdp find the
mdp where
i get the maximum average report and i
will define average award soon but
find the most optimistic mdp the best
mdp that according to
within this set of mvps and then compute
the optimal policy for this optimistic
mdp
run it through this episode and then
have a certain criterion for when the
episode ends
okay so that's the high level
description of the algorithm
so let's make things more concrete using
some notation
so t k will be the start time of episode
k
and i was talking about statistics so
let's give them
some notation n k s of a
is the count for this particular state
in action
just prior to the start of episode k
okay so for all taus less than p
t k how many times did i end up in this
state
in my history okay this is n sub k
is just before the start of episode k so
all the way from episode one through k
minus one
i sum them up and i put them in m k of s
a and also the the counts for the
triplets
so the transition from s a to s s prime
i also maintain a
counter for that
the the third statistic i maintain is
the reward right the
so the the um
the total reward that i have gathered
in a particular state action pair
combination
and these statistics will give me
estimates point estimates so right now i
don't have a set i have a particular
single mdp which is my estimate for what
the true mdp might be i can
obviously divide the capital rk the
total sum of rewards
by the count that's my estimate for how
good this state is in terms of the
immediate reward
and then i can also divide the triples
by
the the count for the pair essay and
that's my
maximum likelihood estimate for the for
that entry the s prime
s a entry of the transition function
that's a point estimate
and at this point an algorithm designer
might say
well i have an estimate let me just
compute the optimal policy and follow it
for a while you can do that that's that
has names it's
sometimes called certainty equivalence
uh in control
you just believe your point estimate or
the greedy strategy in cs
and the problem with that is you can get
stuck in your own self beliefs so even
in a simple problem like bandit if you
just go with the point estimate
uh it's very easy to show that you can
have linear regret which is like the
maximum weight that you can ever get
um so not a good idea to just believe
the point estimate and do the optimal
for that
in general i mean there might be more
special structure which makes
certainty equivalents look good and
certainly people do care about
situations where you can prove that it's
not such a bad idea to be greedy or
have the certainty equals uh principle
in picture but in general it's not good
yeah so we will create a set of
plausible mdp's
around our estimates
and this is maybe a strange looking
definition so my set of
plausible mdps what is an mdp
i have already a fixed state and a fixed
action space there is no discounting
here because i'm looking at
uh one long sort of one long continuous
trajectory so
i will actually use average reward as my
criteria for optimality
so there's no discount factor state and
action space are already fixed so what
is an mdp it's just
a reward function and a transition
function so to create a set of mdps i
need to just create sets of reward
functions and transition functions how
do i create them
well the reward function is any function
rsa such that for all s and a
it's close enough to my point estimate
and similarly for the
for the transition function where do the
right hand where does the right hand
side come from
comes from concentration inequalities
typically with only
n k s a visits to s a you will not have
high confidence
uh at an accuracy more than one over
square root n right so it directly comes
out of standard
independent uh standard like coefficient
zuma type of concentration
and the log terms are there to handle
the fact that you want these intervals
to hold
uh uniformly over time because you're
going to take many union bounds over
time and over
state an action pair so there are
logarithmic terms and the delta
uh will become obvious very soon the
delta will be the standard
uh thing in probabilistic analysis
algorithms where the algorithm
will fail uh its theoretical guarantee
will fail with some
small probability so obviously if delta
goes very small then your conscious
intervals have to become larger and
the last thing i want you to notice on
this slide is an extra square root of s
in the second inequality and this is
because we are using a very strong
notion of locality around the point
estimate for a transition function uh
i'm using the l1 norm which is the so
p of um this may be badly written i
shouldn't have written s prime here i
should have written a
a dot here so i'm thinking of the
transition function as a as a function
of s a which is
going to be a vector and that vector has
length s
and so i take the l one norm between
them and that's
and that's why there's a square root s
because i have a very strong norm i want
this norm to be small so i have to pay
that square root s factor
another way to see this presence of a
square root s is that it's a very well
known equality
says that this l one distance between
two probability distributions which is
called also called the total variation
can equivalently be thought of as the
maximum
disagreement between two probability
distributions maximum over
all possible 2 to the power s sets
right so i have a distribution over s
states i can ask what is the probability
for
state 1 13 and 17 some number
and i can take all possible sets and ask
for what is the maximal disagreement
between two probability vectors
over all two to the s states and that is
uh i think it's just a constant factor
away from element distance and so so
if you think about taking a union over
all those two to the power assets then
you naturally get that square root s
so so the confidence in interval for the
transition functions is
wider
okay so what is the actual optimism i'm
going to do
now i'm deviating a little bit for ease
of exposition
from the actual paper the actual paper
uses something called extended value
iteration they actually do everything in
efficiently and and chava's book is even
more
uh i think the mdp chapter in the book
banded algorithms by java and tor
they're even more careful about proving
that things are polynomial time so so
they use linear programming
i'm going to be much more cavalier about
this aspect of computational efficiency
i just assume that somehow over the set
of plausible mvps
you can find out the one which has the
maximum
optimal long-term reward so row star of
m
is the in a given mdpm
it's the best average reward you can get
and i will define it
you know in a later stage but right now
just think of it intuitively as the best
so long-term average reward than any
policy can give you and then
the mdpm and then i'll conceptually i'll
search over all mdps
uh with finite diameter and i will
explain again i'll explain what the
diameter is
in the actual paper they don't have this
constraint of searching only over finite
diameter mvps
in fact they show they show that once
you do the extended value iteration the
diameter of the mdp you find will be
will be not too big but just for ease of
exposition let's say let's say some we
are given a bound on the diameter of the
2mdp
so i constrain my mdp space over the set
of possible mdps that have small
diameter
and within them i choose the one which
has maximum optimal reward
and tilde quantities will be optimistic
quantities
so there is some true mdp m i have a
point estimate m hat
at any given time and then there is an m
tilde computed at the start of every
episode
so tilde quantities are optimistic
hacks are estimates and if you don't
have any superscript then that's just
the true mvp
so i also have a python decay which is
the optimal policy for this optimistic
mbpm tilde
and then just follow this python decay
in this episode until
what happens until some state action
pair
gets its count gets doubled okay so
we k will be the notation for the count
within this episode and once we k
reaches n nk which was the count just
prior to the episode i'll say
if it happens for any particular essay
pair i'll say okay episode over
start a new music and this doubling
this definition that involves doubling
make sure that the number of episodes
will remain logarithmic
in time okay so we k is the vegetation
count
within an episode and n k is the
count just prior to an episode so
obviously you have the recurrence
relation that nk
plus 1 is nk plus vk
okay so i was talking about the long
term average award so i'll define it
here
so if you have an mdp and let's say you
have a
policy pie which could even be
non-stationary
even though with enough assumptions you
can show that a stationary policy
can give you optimality but suppose you
have an m a policy pi and a starting
state s
you can define the average reward simply
as the limb suit of this average
right so you sum up all the rewards in
expectation that you get by running pi
and m starting from state s take the
expected expectation so that becomes a
number
you divide it by t and you let you take
the limit you take the limb soup because
how do you even know the limit exits you
maybe take this to take the lenses
um and an optimal policy
will be one so i'm jumping to the third
bullet an optimal policy will be one
that maximizes
uh rho m pi of s
over all choices of pi and actually if
you assume that the mdp has finite
diameter you can show that
that policy will not depend on the
initial state so same policy can
optimize the average report from
starting from any state and that optimal
average reward will be called row star
fm
so what is this condition involving a
finite diameter that that
has all these nice implications about
the optimal policy not having to depend
on the initial
state fair diameter is very intuitive it
just means that you can
get from any state to any other state
using some policy
in finite time in expectations right so
so in a graph what's the diameter
the diameter of a graph is over two
nodes in the graph
so for any fixed two nodes i'll find the
shortest path and then like what's
the longest shortest path as i arrange
over all pairs of states that's kind of
how that
how big my my my graph is so very
similar definition for mdps
uh take any two states s and s prime
find the policy
pi that transitions fastest from s to s
prime
and by fastest i mean takes the least
amount of time in expectation to go from
s to s prime
and and that's the diameter right it
doesn't depend on the revolved function
it's solely a property of the transition
function
so any questions here so i think we are
getting into notation heavy
uh regime and i want to make sure that
people are not already lost before i've
started to analyze the algorithm
chava are there any i i did answer some
questions
just uh to get you to get a sense uh to
give you a sense of
type of questions uh one question the
very last question was about the
computational complexity of uh
finding an optimistic mdp
and i said it's high yes
yes and especially the optimism is uh is
a big
problem in even more complex problems
like this i even if you know how to
compute the optimal behavior for a given
system
it is a big ask to then say that do this
over a set which may be weird due to the
concentration there are some nice recent
developments uh
gargey also had a paper and also
marca bay and us and rules rick in the
case of
acuras uh very surprisingly sure that
it's possible to do these things so it's
we shouldn't paint an
overly uh black picture here
it's easy to uh over generalize
of what we know and what we don't know
uh
it's true that like straightforward and
this is uh suggests that these problems
are difficult but sometimes you can use
sometimes you can exploit yeah like your
cleverness and special structure like
but on the flip side on the negative
side we do know that
uh even in i think it's true in uh even
linear
uh in linear bandits that
if you have a convex set of actions then
finding the best action is obviously
easy if you have a if you have some kind
of oracle nice oracle access to the set
but doing the optimistic computation i
think there are
sets for which you can show us and be
hard so we know cases where
there's a separation yeah but but uh
usually you can change the problem a
little bit relax things a little bit
that's right and then the question is
how much you're giving up on a regret
and
sometimes you don't actually give up on
worst case regret you just
lose constant factors sometimes you know
it's a bit complicated
but uh it's even for the finite mdp case
we don't quite know uh what would be you
know the precise computational
complexity of finding this optimistic
uh mdps with this avon uh
type of uncertainty right so we don't
have we are not close to understanding
this problem very well
even in finite case
so i thought in in your chapter you
actually show that it can be done in
yeah that's the only thing but like
complexity
i don't know like some big number 26
yeah yeah but who knows it's probably
smaller but but it's still high
yeah good question about yeah the
competition around the optimistic
combination there are still open
questions
i think chaba is right we shouldn't
necessarily paint a very negative
picture but
you know it could it could be hard and
and maybe you can get away from the
hardness
by relaxing behalf of the audience some
of the questions
uh i'm not sure if i understand but is
diameter and upper bound on the distance
and if yes how do we initialize this
on the distance i think it's it's a
distance
in terms of like how many time steps uh
you need to travel
oh it is exactly that t s prime is
literally the sum of
time steps that it will take for policy
files
it's also called the hitting time i
think in markup chains like how much
time it takes you to get to a certain
state
yeah and uh so there was the second part
of the question
how do we initialize this
i think you should clarify here uh what
the argument will really need to know
about the dialect
algorithm you don't need to know much
you just need to know the state space
and and and actions so you're
simplifying things by assuming that the
time assuming you know about right but
that's not you don't need to
don't need to know actually you can show
that if you remove that constraint
the algorithm is still fine right right
i just didn't want to prove that yeah so
i just use it and then like you have to
use a separate argument that optimism
only reduces the diameter
it is somewhat obvious though right
because the true mdp
is in your set it has some diameter now
you have even more transitions
more things right how can the
connectivity reduce you all you can only
get better connecting
your travel time is going to reduce
right so you can okay
so can somebody clear up the definition
of tilde mk
for me it appears the type in the
definition on page
12 in the subscript of arcmax okay
till the mk is you have a set of mdps
and suppose you're doing this extra
constraint
i guess it should be a calligraphic set
uh
because that is oh oh oh oh yeah that's
that's wrong yeah yeah that's just a
typo it should be a
so that is calligraphic
yeah then you you do the optimization
over the calligraphic set so this
should be a calligraphic sorry
okay i think you're on the same page no
more questions yeah everyone's
happy i think
okay let me stay optimistic one more
question
can you clarify again why you use the
avon distance for the transition
i totally come clear in the analysis
i'll point out why we need the admin
distance we'll use and
technical reason as we use the l one l
infinity
inequality to boundary term and that's
where you need your l1 control
okay good and that could be and
and okay i'll say something about extra
factors in this algorithm so i'll make
some comments about l1
okay so okay so we so we know what the
algorithm does and and we now know what
the diameter is and that makes sure that
you have
a well-defined optimal average reward um
the last technical piece of machinery i
need uh before we can
start analyzing the algorithm i have
what 20 more minutes is that right
okay good um so the
average reward bellman equation these
are slightly different um
from the discounted case uh and they
also have less uniqueness
so everything is somehow more subtle
with average reward but
but but here they are and again if you
have finite diameter then existence
and everything is taken care of you have
solutions the optimal policy is going to
satisfy
an equation like this the number rho
star
plus a function h star of s will equal
uh the reward the immediate reward that
you get in s by
when you do pi star and s plus uh
plus sort of the the usual thing right
the average of under the next state
distribution of the same function that
you have on the left hand side
unfortunately to introduce more
complications this bias vector which is
kind of the analog of value function
is not unique in the average reward case
and you can see this in this equation
already i can add a constant to every
element of h star and because i hit it
with the probability
it's just going to give me that constant
right hand side and i get the same
constant on the left hand side so it can
all entries of a star can shift by a
constant and it's still a solution
in fact it's even less unique than that
so so
uh it still is not unique but certainly
it exists there is one h star that will
satisfy this uh
bellman equation and we will use this
bellman equation in the analysis
the second uh technical information i
need is
the span of h star what is the span of h
star
it's simply the the range the minimum to
maximum
the span of h-star it's very easy it's
it's not that difficult to show that
it's actually upper bounded by the
diameter
and so if you have some kind of
convention to normalize these these
bias vectors maybe the minimum entry
will always normalize them to zero
because you have this freedom of
shifting them
if you normalize them let's say the
minimum value is zero then the infinity
norm and the span
are the same okay and we will use this
fact we will bound the infinity number
of h star by the diameter
okay so now begins the sort of regret
analysis
what is going to be the regret it's the
difference between t
star times the optimal reward so if you
know the mdp
you can compute rho star m and you just
multiply by
by that by t that's a very good
yardstick
to to shoot for and you will subtract
your accumulated rewards from that
yardstick to say that's my regret
and it's a function of the mdp you're in
it's the function of the algorithm
script a that you're using
it also depends on where it potentially
could depend on where you start from
and the total and the main theorem in
the ucl2 paper is that with high
probability
regret is bounded for any starting state
s
in any t
and for any mdp that has a finite
diameter
by d s
outside the square root and then inside
the square root 80 with some long terms
okay so you get a linear dependence in
state space a square root dependence on
action
square root on t and and and linear
dependence on diameter
okay so now um i'll see how much of the
analysis i can go through let me let me
actually
at least give you the basic idea and
then i might have to transition over to
the discussion section
because i am running out of time
so how do we analyze this algorithm the
nice thing is the algorithm doesn't
change the policy within an episode
so you can decompose this business of
this this task of
controlling the regret to controlling
the per episode regret
um what is the per episode regret
the per episode regret is just it's just
a regret in that episode so it's
uh this term over here the counts
to different states and actions during
that episode remember that was vk
that times the the sort of
the difference between the optimal
average reward and the reward you get in
that state
that's how much regret you incur in
episode k
and the total regret is just a sum of
these regrets
and i already told you that because of
the doubling criterion
it's fairly easy to show that they're
not going to be more episodes than s
a and then log of t to base two
or or to any any basic since we're only
looking at
uh things without without precise
constants
the actual bound actually has a precise
constant so it's not order
uh you can actually get an actual
constant it's
34 uh but i'm not going to keep track of
constants in my presentation
so once you once you look at per episode
regret
the first thing you do is you first show
that you are actually optimistic
that the the standard the concentration
that you're using
actually ensures that the mdp true mdp
will lie it's not gonna escape out of
your set with very high probability
right so standard concentration tells
you that uh
at any given time uh if you constructed
a confidence
set the probability of the true mdp not
being in it is minuscule right delta
over some high power of
t and then using union bounds and stuff
like that
it's it's technical work but
conceptually there's not much going on
you can very easily show
that the contribution of the regret
because of the failure of the confidence
interval
is not more than square root t and it
doesn't even
give you all these extra factors of s a
and u so that's not the dominant term
what's the dominant term the dominant
term is well assume that the
uh your confidence regions were correct
what's what's the regret you incur in
that case
okay so if my confidence intervals are
correct
this possibly is conceptually the heart
of the analysis even though technically
a lot has to come but conceptually this
i feel like this is the heart
so you look at the per episode regret
there's a row star the agent has no idea
what row status
but because it's using optimism and
because we know that the true mdp
is in the set row tilde k
which it can compute is obviously an
upper bound
so i can replace rho star it's
multiplying a positive quantity so i'm
not cheating i can replace it with an
upper bound
and so i get this upper bound on the
regret and interestingly
everything here is computable by the
agent the regret is not computable
because the agent doesn't know what row
star is
but this upper bound that we will
analyze is actually computable by the
engine so we will work with this upper
bound where row star has been replaced
by
pro tilde which is this optimistic which
is the optimal reward in this optimistic
mdp
and also recall the bellman equation for
rho tilde
relman equation says that now i have
written it in vector matrix notation so
rho tilde times a vector of once
plus the bias vector for this policy h
tilde is equal to r tilde k
plus transition this fake transition
kernel p till decay
it's the fake transition kernel because
it doesn't correspond to what actually
happens
it's the transition kernel in p tilde
that corresponds to pi tilde it's a
fictitious quantity doesn't exist in the
real problem
but this equation will be satisfied okay
so our job will be to just massage this
expression before we can start to see
elements of this equation
in the regret um
so what do you do you first of all add a
subtract
and r tilde so you have rho tilde minus
r you you subtract and subtract r tilde
why do you do that
well because you know that r tilde and r
are close
they're closed because that's how you
you generated the set there
so this term doesn't actually create a
lot of trouble
um or in other words can be handled by
terms that are strictly smaller than
what this term contributes
so the dominant contribution to the
regret comes from this
visitation count weighted difference
between rho tilde and
r tilde
and this is actually nice because i can
use my bellman equations
so i know that the bellman equation
holds and i have a difference between
rho tilde and r tilde that's kind of
interesting because the difference
between rotal and r tilde can be
transformed into um
using the bellman equation between so
you i can replace rho tilde
time times 1 minus r tilde simply
uh p tilde times h tilde k
minus h to the k so just move this r
tilde over to the left hand side
h tilde to the right hand side and that
explains the last step here
okay so in some sense it's very nice
like once you do this optimistic
thing that you replace rho star by rho
tilde the rest of it is extremely
natural it's almost like what you might
try given the fact that you have to use
the bellman equation somewhere
so it follows very naturally
and now we are left now the dominant
term in the analysis
is this this type of term where the
visitation counts
we are taking inner product of that with
p tilde h minus h tilde which can be
factorized
as p tilde k minus identity times h
and recall that um
p tilde is a fictitious transition
kernel it's a transition kernel of pi
tilde in a fictitious mdp
but pi tilde has a real transition
kernel in the real mdp
so let's call it let's call that p and
this is the
last step in the analysis then then it
is just calculations
so once we have arrived at the
difference looking at the difference
between p tilde and i
you just say i'm gonna add and subtract
p k
which is the transition kernel of pi
tilde your optimistic policy
in the true mdp which you don't know but
we are doing the analysis so that's okay
we can use it in analysis the algorithm
never
uses pk it cannot it doesn't know it
so we add and subtract pk and what's
interesting is
that uh you can sort of start to see why
both of these terms will be easily
not so hard like won't be that hard to
control the term involving p tilde k and
p
that's very similar to the term
involving r delta and r
that's going to be small because you
know you have some control on how far
the how big the optimistic set is you
have some control on how
how big people then p killer minus p
can be so that will that control will
come from your construction of
the possible set of possible mvps a
little bit of intuition about the second
term here
we have the visitation counts in episode
k hitting
pk minus r what is pk minus i pk here is
the transition kernel of pi tilde k
if pi tilde k achieved stationarity
at stationarity there would be a
stationary distribution mu sub k
such that p k mu k would just be mu k
that's the definition of stationarity
here i'm not at stationarity i just have
some counts
but you know but it's going to be small
because it's like a random fluctuation
beyond this this term would actually be
zero if vk was replaced by the
stationary distribution of
python decay but we're not at
stationarity so we get a martingale
different sequence plus another
diameter contribution each time the
episode changes but again this does not
give you
the dominant term the dominant term
still remains the first term which is
about controlling p tilde and p because
i have only seven minutes left i am i
will spare
you the the details of the
the math beyond this so conceptually i
think the proof finishes here
you still have to do algebra and
calculus and
control of uh some finite differences to
control this this term over all episodes
uh one thing to answer a question about
why l1 norm that's because of this
dominant term so when you analyze this
dominant term
you get a term where the difference
between p tilde and p k
hits h tilde k what do we know about h
to decay it has
a small span why because the diameter is
small
uh and it's the infinity norm of h tilde
k which is controlled by the diameter so
i can only put an infinity norm here
which forces me to put an l1 norm
on the difference between primary
distributions and that's where
the source that's the source value at
least if you do this analysis i'm not
saying that
there's no other way to do the analysis
but this analysis that's the root of
why why there are now appears
okay so i don't think there's anything
else conceptual i want to say here
this this diameter that you get
from the infinity term just comes out
one square root s
directly comes from the right hand side
of the p tilde concentration
that's one source of s tilde and then
you get a term involving the visitation
counts that are normal
that are normalized by the previous
visitation counts which gives you
another square root s
a t okay so d square root s
times another square root s a t and
that's that's kind of the
you can at least start to see where the
different contributions in the regret
are
coming from and i'll skip this slide why
why that
by the count term gives you a square
with sat
and the obvious question that you might
have at this point as well
we did a lot of bounding some of it
might be loose we're using l1 and
infinity god knows how many
upper bounds we've accumulated how much
we're paying so is this optimal is there
any hope to show a lower bound
in fact the paper does show a lower
bound and a pretty strong lower bound it
says that for
any algorithm uh on any mdp of of
non-trivial size so more than 10 states
and actions
and diameter which is large which which
is
very reasonable log a of s you can show
that the diameter has to be at least
like 3 log a over s or something so this
is not a stringent condition at all
and for any t which is sort of large
enough
the regret is going to be at least
square root of ds80 okay so at least
this the upper bound is capturing all
the the main
sources here the diameter the the state
space action space and time
but of course if you notice that there
is a discrepancy here the upper bound
had d and s
outside the square root while the lower
bound has them inside the square root so
what is the optimal what what
is can we match the lower bound and and
upper bound
the your original paper left this open
but recently
uh there's a there's an archive which i
haven't verified myself so i can't
uh i can't say with full confidence that
it has managed to
to remove the the gap uh it's
not published yet it's just a preprint
but the claim is
uh that it's the lower bound that's type
so the upper bound can be improved
uh and and the b and the d and the
square root s and
i think the idea is that uh one one
factor of uh
sphero d you can avoid by just using
more interesting concentration quality
so if you're using
the most naive concentration equalities
you can use things like bernstein
that will give you one source of
improvement
and i think also this uh l1 norm
business i think they do
in the paper does a different
construction of optimistic mdps but
what's interesting is that that
overall is still uci so they call that
algorithm uclb
and and pending checks and i think this
would be a good
reading material for a reading group you
could spend some time looking at this
proof to see
how the gap is illuminated
so the three minutes that i have i will
not say anything about thomson sampling
except that in thomson sampling instead
of creating a plausible set
you work with the posterior which means
that you have to have a prior
you look at the data you get a posterior
over mdps you draw an mdp from that
poster
and you just compute the optimal policy
so you don't you don't have this
optimism
inbuilt you might still have some
probabilistic optimism because maybe
there's some probability that you'll be
optimistic
but posterior sampling has been taken
outside of its banded origins
actually very old algorithm back going
back to 1933
and and we have we have tools to analyze
posterior sampling but i don't have time
right now to go into the analysis
um what has happened since ucl2 it's 10
years ago so a lot has happened
other algorithmic ideas including
townsend sampling injecting random noise
random noise could be injected into
the trajectory maybe you randomly
perturb the trajectory you could perturb
value functions
so this idea that maybe we don't need
full-blown optimism maybe we can just
add some randomness and hope that that
will inject enough probabilistic
optimism
so that i can still prove written bounds
that those algorithmic ideas are
definitely in the air and there are
papers on some of these already
but more remains to be done you can also
look at
uh other i i was looking at average
reward
which makes sense if you have one long
trajectory but certainly you can look at
episodic problems where there are resets
there's work on on
on episodic setting as well all the
algorithms i talked about today e cube
rmax
and ucl are model based because they
basically maintain a model
you might ask what happens if you have
model free algorithm that has
also been studied and large state spaces
whether you talk about factored mdps or
function approximation and then within
function approximation as java mentioned
uh yesterday recently there has been a
lot of work on the linear mdp place
and you can prove rigorous bounds in
that scenario and just infer the tabular
case as a special
case where the dimensionality is just s
times
a so that has happened and between this
is also
coming to the edge of the frontier of
knowledge this a lot of these issues are
still being
addressed some other issues that um i'm
quite interested in
are are aspects related to transfer and
curriculum learning
uh learning on one task using that
knowledge another task
choosing maybe tasks the agent itself
can choose the order of the task
or maybe it's given to the agent all of
those how to analyze those situations
theoretically i think is a fascinating
uh open area also causality
um you know can be can we use some type
of causal modeling
uh and can it help with especially with
transfer because there's this intuition
that maybe causality has to do with
things that are invariant
under various perturbations of the
system so if you can learn something
common across a lot of tasks and encode
that commonality
in some in some causal way maybe you can
enable
transfer learning in rl and analyze it
theoretically
i assume that states are perfectly
observed um you can have obviously in
most
real problems you have partial
observability there are some papers
uh dealing with it the computational
problem just goes up because even if as
java mentioned yesterday even if you
know the system
uh i don't know if it was java or mainly
one of them said that this p space
hardness results
for computing optimal policies for form
dps uh but maybe you you define regret
with respect to a less burdensome
comparative you can say my competitor
also is
is bounded computationally and i just
want to regret against a computationally
bounded competitor
and then finally multi-agent rl where
you don't have a single agent but
you have multiple agents what does
regret even mean
are we trying to convert to some
equilibria so there are many interesting
questions on multi-plan
uh i did go over a little bit but i'm
happy to
stop here the summary is stating the
obvious you can read it
uh and my slides will be available uh i
already posted them on
on discord and all the references in
part of the talk are at the end
thank you yeah thanks ambuj
sure andrea clap
yeah in the meanwhile i try to answer
the other questions uh
i think that some people were just
wondering about this optimism
and uh why like
again an intuitive understanding of why
optimism does
that's hard um
[Music]
right question about what stops us from
getting stuck
well he's following one policy and
therefore not exploring
well you switch to new policy right okay
i guess
like soboro was asking this uh
sequence of questions uh which tries to
uh poke at like how optimism helps like
why not use the point estimates and so
so forth i was just saying that
oh just think about what happens in
bandits uh but maybe that example could
be explained a little bit more i i
couldn't type up you know like a
detailed answer
so maybe you could just like uh see a
few words about
uh why does it happen that
uh if you're in a bandit then it is
special case of mdp
so if you are yes traveling right so
yeah right so just believe in your point
estimate it's very easy to show it's bad
even in a banner even with just two
actions which is kind of the
least sort of interesting case if it's
just one action then anything you do is
optimal
okay so even with two actions um
you have you have an action which is
better an action which is
worse according to its true mean uh but
but but but these are not deterministic
right so there is some randomness
maybe the first time you try both of
them
the better one gives you a sample which
is lower
right so you think that oh the better
one is
is lower so okay so i'm going to just uh
go with the other one that arm's
estimate will get continuously refined
but it will remain above
your poor estimate based on one sample
of the other arm you just get
you'll be forever stuck in this false
belief and the problem is you
you putting too much trust in that one
sample from the veteran you thought that
it was wrong
you will never have optimism fixes this
optimism because eventually
the the um
[Music]
the the width of the worst arm is going
to shrink
but the width of the big arm is not
shrinking so at some point the upper
confidence bound will still
be up so you will be forced to try the
other one and then hopefully you will
not
uh you know with high probability the
estimate the random samples do give you
a good idea
and so the same reasoning works in on
the pieces so
in a nutshell i think so i think in a
nutshell
it's kind of the the the issue is uh
actually in mdps if you look at lqr
systems i think there's a very nice
geometry of
what is the manifold it's actually a
very nice geometry in iq system
in mdps there's no geometry it's all
discrete but in lq systems there's a
geometry you can start understanding
what is the manifold of
sort of uh systems
where you get trapped in this false
belief
so you have a you have a system
you have a controller your controller on
the system produces know it's just a
it's just a markov process that is the
only that's the process that will give
you information
if you don't change the policy and you
can say that
well based on the information that i get
what systems will kind of be
indistinguishable
and if there is a gap in in sort of
optimal rewards between those systems
like you don't have any information to
distinguish between them so
the the bet on the best principle paper
by
um uh vitanti and campy that i have
referred to
they have a nice discussion
about how optimism allows you to escape
this
sort of you get you get stuck in this
fixed point where you you get data but
that data is from your own
sort of falsely believed estimate and
you get sort of get stuck
in in circular reasoning almost and
optimism
and they have a very nice discussion of
how optimism allows you to escape
from that vicious sort of vicious loop
of belief
okay so there is uh another question um
from sebastian
he says as far as i understand the
transition function reward function
treated as statistically independent but
ucrl2
maybe no noise right in them is treated
as statistically independent maybe
that's that's what is man
statistically independent what if there
is some known dependence between the two
so that
for example observed rewards are also
informative toward the transition
function
i imagine we should be able to do better
in subsetting
is there any work in the setting that
you know oh i think i understand that
yeah okay so you i think by statistical
independence you just mean that i'm
allowing
all the rewards like i'm taking a
partisan product to sort of allow
rewards and allowed
conditions yeah it's like condition on
where you are
the noise in the reward and the noise in
the transition
could be dependent or could be
and the analysis doesn't really care
about if
they are dependent or independent uh
whether there is any room for
improvement
if there was uh some dependence
uh but i guess i uh
go ahead uh i don't know like i have
some sort yeah my i mean my preliminary
feeling about this question is but i
first of all i don't know of any
an actual paper that would answer your
question but my guess right now is
the principle still applies you it will
your it will your estimation will become
more complicated so you will have to
estimate
p and r jointly maybe okay
because right like if you have
dependencies then you
sort of have less information
like it's like flipping two coins or
flipping one coin
like you're interested in the means and
right if
the more independence you have the sort
of the more effective yeah that's my
god feeling uh but uh if you had
dependence
uh you would need to apply an extra
union bond
and the analysis would go through so
it's like a log tool
or something like that would be lost i
think
yeah shouldn't be a big issue
i feel like that's that's right um but
i think that there is an underlying
different question which is
related which is the structured mvp
setting where maybe you know like you
see a reward of
0.7592
at this state extreme pad and from that
know that this was your mdp
and then uh you know like there could be
some
uh structured mvp setting uh
and and that that's interesting and how
to go about that
uh are there any papers that uh you have
seen about this
uh i mean structure i have seen papers
on like there's analysis of optimism
based and
and the end times sampling in the
factored case
um but i don't think that gets to
exactly what you're saying but that's
yeah so i think that that is one one
paper i can think about maybe we can
post the
uh pointer later uh yeah we can use
discord i'm trying to build a
bibliography of sort of interesting
variants of basic regret analysis i
think discord is a good way
to collectively use the crowd's wisdom
too
okay so we have plenty of questions i'm
happy to stay
if people need to leave they can leave
yeah i think officially we are done so
if people
are officially done uh if you need to
you know get uh some exercise or fresh
air or whatnot
uh but uh i i'm happy to also gather
down i think yeah i get a town uh but i
think that for answering the questions
this is actually a little bit better
than gather town and get it on like
that's true i don't know like
it would take time to get together and
like i would we would lose the questions
okay esme says uh could you please
introduce any paper with theoretical
results
that uses transfer learning this online
rl
so i think min doesn't mendy have a
recent paper on uh
might be multitask not transferred but i
think she has something
yeah i don't remember i'm not even sure
if might be you you are on it
because i just can't keep one
but uh if i find this i i think the
answer is yes and i don't i once i have
the precise reference i'll post it on
discord let me make it yeah i think we
should just post
i i know about a few papers uh i think
maybe i'm on that set of paper
emma might yeah
and i think that they do have yeah emma
and lihong lee had the paper on
like sample complexity issues right yes
yeah yeah yeah
yeah there are there are papers for sure
we just need
some time to pick them up yeah and and
if you ask you guys can ask these
questions in discord so like everyone
and uh we'll be there and we try to
answer how to understand the stopping
criterion
of episodes uh and i would add to that
uh so this channel's question i would
add to that that
how important it is to use these
episodes and this
stuffing criteria are there other ways
to cut the episodes
uh what if we don't have episodes
yeah so there is an exercise actually in
chapels
chapter that shows that if you if you
don't have any like if you just keep
changing it each time then that's
that's not a good idea so you definitely
need to wait
uh and let the policy run for a while um
so so that's one part of what i wanted
to say the other part is well how
important is it to do it precisely in
this way of like you wait till some
state action doubles
i don't think it's i don't think it's
that important to do it in precisely
that way
there are there are i think plenty other
uh strategies for episodes some of them
even like you can just
if you know the time resonant advance i
think you can do something fairly simple
uh to change the episode so i i wouldn't
say that
that doubling is somehow a crucial piece
i think the crucial piece is the
construction of the optimistic mdps
uh doing the optimism and then sticking
for the policy
for a while like you certainly don't
want to recompute each time
i think that's the sense the rest is uh
i think you could you could you could
argue that
other choices could have been made and
have been made actually for posterior
sampling
one of the problems with this uh
with this definition of episode changes
is that a crucial step
in the in the bayesian regret analysis
of term sampling gets
stuck because your episode length is not
a measure it's not measurable with
respect to the history you had in there
at the start of the episode so the
solution of the problem was to redefine
the episode changing rule
so that you actually get measurability
uh and there were some there were some
incorrect statements made that you know
you could just
do the basic regret analysis and then i
think ben van roy had an archive reprint
about why it's not so obvious it's a
subtlety
and so yes this episode changing
business had you have some flexibility
and in fact that flexibility has been
exploited
to prove base and regret of constant
sampling in this infinite
trajectory business
chava would you qualify for that
it's good um oh okay
oh it's uh you should have come up
earlier
why do some people prefer frequent
disregard analysis
chava you want to take that first
because you're you have uh maybe have a
more
longer-term perspective on things oh
well i i think
so the patient regretting that is this
so to me
uh the fewer assumptions
you're making about the problem you're
solving
the stronger the result is a sense that
is a
clear advantage to the frequencies
regret analysis
and i think that that's probably the
answer that
most people who care about frequent
disregard analysis would give you
the only question is why are there
people who don't care about the frequent
disregard and that is to me oh so you're
flipping the question
uh yeah i'm i'm totally positive about
like i
i really do care about you know like
removing assumptions removing
assumptions removing assumptions
and how far you can push this and and in
this sense like patient rig retinalis
stops a little bit earlier and then
what's miraculous though is
that a lot of times a lot of times the
arguments designed for the bayesian
case still survive maybe with some
little modifications sometimes you
actually do have to modify them
to get uh reasonable regret so there's
some recent paper
uh that shows this for nina bennett's uh
and turned on something but okay so i
would flip this question
yeah i think you're talking to people
who inherently are frequent
so i'm i'm the same as java there yeah i
won't bounce that i know just hold like
in base integrate you're saying an
average over some dirichlet prior like
how do we know maybe those mtps are too
simple
being a good scientist means that you're
agnostic as much as you can
and you only make assumptions where you
when you have reasons to believe
uh and the assumptions that are just
convenient are not
not a good reason to to
there's a question about reductions do
we know of reductions bayesian to
frequentist
um i think this
you can make a very simple conclusion
which i think ben when one of his paper
has it which if you know that
expectation of regret is less you can
apply a markov or something and say that
there is a large probability set on
which the frequent
cigarette is bounded so you can do
something very simple like that um
i don't know if reductions i'll just
echo what chavo was saying before is
that
it's often the case and i don't know is
there a deeper reason but it's often the
case that you
design a base an algorithm and
which you can actually analyze it using
frequency analysis
and surprisingly uh confidence intervals
again show up
but only in the analysis not not in the
algorithm itself
obviously i don't like that when that
shows up
if you try to analyze expected regret in
a patient setting
i think you are butchering butchering
the problem
if you bring in confidence or
concentration based bonds
no but if you if you want a frequentest
bound for a bayesian algorithm
oh yeah okay yeah but then for the
patient analysis
oh yeah for the basic analysis no no
yeah yeah you turn
to basically doing the well some part of
the frequent distinguishes
which uh is less than idea i understand
why
you have an idea with it or i've done it
too uh
but uh if there is a way to avoid it
then maybe you can get tighter bonds
okay so there is um a question i
just appeared it is always better to
turn a palm dp problem into mvp
for problems that can be turned into
mdps if enough observation are stacked
together
for example when the actual state is too
large
is that a trade-off in terms of
convergence rate i think this relates to
the question of that
in these analysis uh we assume that the
states are observed
uh and and they're like a minimal
representation of the state is observed
like
you can imagine many other things you
can imagine that you are
clamping together a few past
observations
in the video game and then you have this
overblown representation of the state um
hoping that like okay that's a state
representation that is a voted state
uh but uh it may not be a state that's
the first problem or if it's a state
it's an overblown representation so what
what do you say for people who
worry about these things
you're asking me uh about games i don't
think i'll have much to say
i think actually has some american trees
around
uh at least uh answering partly parts of
this question
it's an active uh area of research
uh trying to understand uh
oh one paper where something like this
is happening theoretically
is a paper uh
actually by ronald ortner on on restless
bandits
where it is a pom dp but they converted
into an mdp
but it but they actually truncate the
state pace becomes countably infinite so
they have to truncate it
and i i've often worried about in that
special case of restless bandits if
if there is some optimal truncation
um and and i think that's related to the
question here because the question here
is i could just keep my palm dp
and my omni period in bounds
or i could enlarge the state space and
apply amnesia grounds how do i compare
these two and is there as
as those assets that are trade off
between commerce results
i think the question is very interesting
as java said i think you're still
trying to understand some of these
issues
last question oh no not last but uh
ibrahim
jamal shah is asking thompson's
questions do we know reductions from
patient to frequent disregard
i think i already discussed that right
yeah okay
for terms of sampling every time sample
from our posterior viscosity
can be a big use of them by having a fly
on policies that we can update the prior
from the optimal policy of the separate
mdp and then simple policy
that we used to act on the password on
the episode from or
prior on policies
so here i guess the desire is to not
keep a poster at the level of models but
just keep it at the level of policies
is that the question yeah it's pretty
much i think
um
i think for value functions certainly
certainly there's work uh of that flavor
where you don't want to do like
thompson sampling or well i don't think
you can call you i don't think you can
actually
call something that only operates at the
level of
value functions or policies some
thompson sampling technically because
you like you don't have the full
parameter space somehow but
but thompson sampling type algorithms
definitely exist where you add
randomness or posterior type objects at
the level of value functions
for policies i'm not sure sure actually
i don't know if there's a paper that
says
there are expert type algorithms like
polytech type business where you
maintain
some weighted distribution of our
policies yeah
it's hard to say that that's possible
you know like putting
uh distributions over value functions
uh that used to be a core
topic in bayesian rl um
it's not too active these days other
papers where ucl type of
arguments are used but instead of
looking at big debt we are more
interested in finite time analysis like
uh how close the you know like the very
function
policy is to optimal oh yes by by by no
means is regret analysis the only
theoretical yeah this is more like uh
you don't
care about like exploration costs pure
explanation
i mean mdps yeah again there's a i think
there's a line of work the
one i that's come to my mind right now
is emily kaufman has a recent paper on
pure exploration there there is a bunch
like at least three groups you're
working on
yeah and you can look off references of
that so there is definitely work
i don't want i should maybe i should
have pointed this out that the regret is
just what i focused on but it's by no
means the only
it's a very reasonable if you're online
most of the time you would care about
regret but maybe sometimes
uh you're given a free pass for a vibe
and then
after that there is no learning i find
that not too natural
but uh maybe external circumstances are
such that you
really have to do that um
oh there's somebody's trying to make an
analogy between simplex and
ellipsoid and on one hand and
frequentest and bayesian i
oh i i don't see the analogy
uh what is what is the analogy
the tension between frequencies and base
and regret is
i don't think it's the same tension as
i mean there is some commonality because
simplex is is
is exponential in the worst case but you
know it's smooth complexity is
polynomial
uh so so i kind of see what what this
question is getting at
but it i can't make it precise i think
the analogy isn't quite
yeah um you could and actually chaba i
wanted to
pick your brains about this is that we
have worst case
what we call frequency analysis so give
me a bound for all mdps
we have bayesian which is averaged over
some prior
there is uh there is smooth analysis in
theoretical computer science right which
is
between average case and worst case
where you say that i'll take the worst
case
i'll add a perturbation around the word
space and i'll look for polynomial
bounds in the amount of perturbation and
the relevant quantities
do you think there is any role for a
smooth
analysis type of framework that sits
somewhere between worst case and
expected i don't see
of gaining much from doing
this in the settings that people
typically look at
i think in uh critical computer science
you do this
uh to show that the adversary who
chooses the worst case instance is kind
of weak
because if you add a little bit of noise
then its bar
is quickly dropping i think the
adversaries here are kind of
noisy already and they have a lot of
power because
of noise and if you add more noise
it man like it's not going to make
the learner's job easier right
so the first case is not like it's not
not that bad the worst is not that bad
in our case
it's just information theoretical worst
case
hold on it's not bad let's say for ucl
too but let's we talk about
and smooth analysis has shown up in this
greedy
so we just we were just talking about oh
greedy is bad because in the worst case
it's bad right
yeah but maybe if you did a smooth
analysis of greedy
yeah yeah okay you you could you could
change to mars that way
yeah then some model could be yeah okay
so
again back to the simplex uh and that is
that the smooth energies of same black
shows this
simplex is not actually that bad um
right right sure uh i think that people
do
smooth analysis in a in an effort to
understand
why certain arguments behave the way
they behave in practice
like surprisingly well uh
when the worst case analysis shows that
they shouldn't be
uh very good at least in the worst case
and uh and that's that's an attempt to
explain that
and yeah in this regard
i know of papers for example it's not
really smooth
oh i i see that some people did analysis
of greedy
uh argutime in linear bandit setting
this smooth analysis
yes that's the paper i'm referring to
yeah because then you can show that
greedy is not that bad because of
and you can kind of see right like the
gap if i if i randomly perturb the means
then obviously there will be some gap so
so maybe maybe the the case where greedy
really fails is like some tiny
region in the space of all problems i
don't believe in that because if you
just
think about the finite and banded case
how the greedy algorithm fails in that
case it is
finite no yeah i think but that that
paper is in the context
linear contextual case yeah and then
there are
i think that there are other reasons to
believe
that the linear contextual case may not
be that bad because
for example you could have benign
context uh distributions or whatnot
and i would rather try to understand
what that is benign settings
then you know artificially add some
noise
and like analyze so you get exploration
for
free in some sense yes there are some
benign cases and then
design an algorithm that is adaptive to
that
and you know like turns down exploration
when you don't need exploration and
turns up exploration when you need
exploration rather than just
saying that oh no greedy is good overall
because like this analysis shows
that uh if we add sufficient amount of
noise
then uh it's not that bad that seems to
be
a bit weaker than what you can do i
think that we are not
in such a dire situation that we would
need to do this
yeah maybe one day i think you're right
i think this the smooth analysis was
trying to grapple with a decades-long
question of why is the simplex in
practice so good
if we had that type of situation in rl
but we had an algorithm which was
amazing but its
theoretical bounds were exponential then
we would maybe worry about yeah
gentlemen i'm sorry to interrupt can i
have uh
oh